a police hunt is underway right now for
a second teenager wanted in connection
with a deadly stabbing of a New York
City College student Barnard freshman
tessa majors died after being stabbed
last wednesday here in a city park now
police have already arrested a 13 year
old who has admitted that he was part of
a group robbing majors and he says that
he watched his his friend stabbed and
choked her nikki batise is outside the
manhattan family court where there's a
hearing to you today good morning to you
Nikki the more we hear about this case
the worse it gets what can you tell us
about this second suspect
Gail good morning while CBS News just
confirmed that the 14 year old
considered a suspect was actually being
driven in for police questioning by a
family member when he escaped from the
car police then launched an hours-long
search but so far they have not found
the teen the 13 year old already in
custody allegedly had ID'd him police
had searched a pond in the park for
evidence
sources say no murder weapon has been
found and there were no eyewitnesses the
13 year olds name has not been made
public but the NYPD says he confessed he
watched his two friends attack Tessa
majors the team could be arraigned today
in family court on charges of felony
second degree murder and robbery he
allegedly told police he went to the
park with two other teens Wednesday
evening to rob someone when his friends
choked majors went through her pockets
and she was stabbed
Tessa majors was a talented musician
from Virginia and it was interested in
journalism she was just finishing up her
first semester at Barnard College and
all women's school associated with
Columbia University it is unclear
whether or not the 13-year old will
appear in court here in person today or
by teleconference as an reportedly told
The Daily News the police have the wrong
suspect that her nephew didn't do this
and Tony an attorney for the boy
declined to comment a murder and now a
manhunt Nikki thank you very much